ein Militärputsch
blutig niedergeschlagene Massenproteste
[Musik]
und ein bewaffneter Widerstand der immer
größer wird
in Myanmar ziehen junge Männer und
Frauen aus allen Ecken des Landes in den
Krieg gegen die Militärdiktatur
en zustoßen könnte
es ist schmerzhaft daran zu denken dass
jemand von uns sterben könnte
Journalisten werden verfolgt und
verhaftet sind gezwungen aus dem Exil zu
berichten
derzeit verstärkt die rumänische runter
ihre Militäroperationen im kajalstaat
wir drehen in Myanmars umkämpften
rebellengebieten treffen Kämpfer in
einer Geheimbasis des Widerstands
Menschen die in diesem Krieg bereit sind
alles zu opfern
das Dach wurde von Kugeln und Raketen
zerstört
[Musik]
wir sind in Myanmar eine Rebellengruppe
bringt uns zu einem ihrer Stützpunkte im
Südosten des Landes nicht weit von der
Grenze zu Thailand
wir sind jetzt mit mehreren Leuten
und Worte
und sollten gleich in den nächsten
Minuten
wahrscheinlich ankommen
dieser Randgebiete Myanmars sind hoch
militarisiert denn hier kämpfen
ethnische Minderheiten schon seit
Jahrzehnten für mehr Selbstbestimmung im
Land
seitdem sich das Militär myanmaß im
Februar 2021 an die Macht geputzt hat
schließen sich auch immer mehr junge
Burmesen aus dem Landesinneren den
Rebellengruppen an zusammen wollen sie
die Militär unterstützen
um hierher zu kommen mussten wir über
Tage mit Informanten sprechen bis
schließlich jemand dazu bereit war uns
auf geheimen Wegen in die
rebellengebiete zu bringen
das ist Kommandeur source er hat uns den
Zugang zu dieser Region ermöglicht
ein Bataillon aus erfahrenen und neuen
Kämpfern an und zeigt uns seinen
Stützpunkt
seinen linken Arm hat er vor einigen
Monaten bei Kämpfen an der Front
verloren erzählt er uns
Moment die Lage hier im Dschungel und
auch in den Städten
in diesen Monaten gibt es schwierige
Gefechte hier in der Region es gab eine
kurze Pause für ein paar Tage doch ich
glaube die Kämpfe werden bald wieder
ausbrechen
wir müssen uns und unsere Equipment also
darauf vorbereiten
manchmal reicht unsere Ausrüstung
manchmal aber auch nicht
der Kommandeur erzählt uns von jungen
Rekruten viele gerade erst volljährig
die an die Front kommen und kämpfen
wollen
mit einigen werden wir sprechen wenn wir
einen seiner anderen Stützpunkte
besuchen
doch zuerst treffen wir eine
Dorfgemeinschaft die hier an der Grenze
zu Thailand Schutz vor dem böhmensischen
Militär sucht die Vertriebenen wirken
verwundert hier ausländische
Journalisten zu sehen kommen aber
neugierig und auch ein wenig verängstigt
auf uns zu
ein 75-jähriger Mann will uns die
Geschichte seiner Flucht erzählen
als der Krieg zu uns kam hat das Militär
unser Dorf zerstört
ich hatte zu viel Angst um dort zu
bleiben also bin ich geflohen
was ich noch in meinem Haus hatte haben
die Soldaten sich genommen
als sie in das Dorf gekommen sind haben
sie Menschen ohne Grund verhaftet und
getötet in so einer Angst konnte ich
dort nicht weiterleben
ihr Dorf lebt mitten im Kampfgebiet wir
wissen nicht ob alle Details stimmen und
ob die unter tatsächlich für die
Gräueltaten verantwortlich ist doch
Menschenrechtsgruppen sprechen von
vielen ähnlichen Fällen die Vereinten
Nation schätzen das seit dem Putsch über
700.000 Menschen vertrieben wurden
rückblick auf den Februar 2021
das burmesische Militär putscht sich an
die Macht die Zivilregierung von enzern
zu Chi wird zerschlagen die
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin verhaftet
Teile der Regierung fliehen ins Exil
min-online der Führer des Militärs der
auch für die brutale Vertreibung der
ethnischen Minderheit der rohenia
verantwortlich war wird zum Staatschef
und macht Myanmar de facto wieder zu
einer Militärdiktatur
[Musik]
die neuen Herrscher greifen hart durch
schränken die Pressefreiheit sofort
massiv ein seitdem können internationale
Medien kaum noch aus dem Land berichten
in den Tagen nach der Macht Ergreifung
berichteten lokale Journalisten unter
großem Risiko von den Protesten und
suchten Wege ihre Bilder an die
Öffentlichkeit zu bringen wir haben uns
mit einigen dieser Journalisten
verabredet die damals hautnah dabei
waren unser Weg führt uns nach Thailand
das ist schwer er und seine Kollegen
mussten ins thailändische Exil fliehen
und betreiben hier das Hauptquartier
ihrer Nachrichtenagentur Delta news
agency in Myanmar selbst wurden
unabhängige Medien verfolgt und Verboten
Informationen dringend fast nur noch
über verschlüsselte Messenger-Dienste
wie telegram oder Signal nach außen
sware und sein Team versuchen die
Bevölkerung von hier aus trotzdem weiter
zu informieren
derzeit verstärkt die burmesische Futter
ihre Militäroperationen im kajastaat sie
mobilisieren bis zu vier oder fünf
Kampfgruppen die lokalen
Verteidigungskräfte sagen sie
koordinieren nach besten Kräften einen
Gegenangriff
sware erzählt uns von den dramatischen
Tagen damals im Februar 2021 er war als
Reporter in Yangon als die demokratisch
gewählte Regierung weggeputscht wurde
es gab also den Staatsstreich und was
ist dann passiert
gegen den Putsch war
von morgen an sind wir den Protesten zu
den Botschaften und durch ganz Jan Gong
gefolgt um darüber zu berichten
er zeigt uns Aufnahmen die er und andere
Journalisten damals gemacht haben
[Musik]
zuerst hat das ganze Land mit
friedlichen Mitteln protestiert
doch das Militär beginnt die Proteste zu
zerschlagen und verhaftet die ersten
Demonstranten woraufhin sich andere in
den straßenverbarrikadieren
[Musik]
dann gab es mehr und mehr
internetblockaden und Restriktionen für
uns Journalisten ist es fast unmöglich
geworden zu arbeiten
es wurde immer gefährlicher für uns
und als auch Tränengas und Bulldozer die
Demonstranten nicht vertreiben beginnt
das böhmische Militär scharf zu schießen
[Musik]
ich habe das Blut vergießen und die
Gewalt mit meinen eigenen Augen gesehen
als ich weggelaufen bin wurde vor mir
ein junger Mann angeschossen und ist zu
Boden gefallen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
nachdem sie ihn hierher getragen haben
ist er noch am selben Ort gestorben
kritischer Journalismus ist heute
lebensgefährlich in Myanmar
Medienhäusern wird mit Strafen gedroht
auch diejenigen die sich für den
Widerstand entschieden haben müssen sich
wegen der zunehmenden Gewalt der Hunter
im Untergrund organisieren
viele ehemals friedliche Protestler
haben sich seit dem Putsch entschlossen
zu den Waffen zu greifen sie verüben
immer wieder Vergeltungsmaßnahmen gegen
die Hunter und tauchen ab und zu zur
Sicherheit in Nachbarländern wie hier in
Thailand unter wir können Kontakt mit
Mitgliedern einer dieser Untergrund
Zellen aufnehmen
die Widerstandskämpfer die sich im
Allgemeinen als peoples defence Force
kurz PDF bezeichnen sind nach langen
Vorgesprächen bereit sich mit uns zu
treffen doch nur unter der Bedingung
dass wir Ihren Standort und ihre
Identitäten geheim halten
man wartet auf uns an einem Treffpunkt
okay ich warte an der Straßenecke vor
dem kleinen Lebensmittelgeschäft unser
Nummernschild ist
der Kontaktmann führt uns zu einem
unscheinbaren Haus
die wenigen Räume sind nur provisorisch
eingerichtet aus Angst ausfindig gemacht
zu werden wollen die Kämpfer nicht dass
wir ihre Gesichter zeigen oder Merkmale
der Umgebung finden abseits der Kamera
sehen wir ein Dutzend junger Männer
einige haben ihre Familien mit hierher
gebracht zwischen Tarnkleidung und
Proviant spielt ein Kind die Mutter
eines der Kämpfer bietet uns Tee an
einer von ihnen ist bereit vor der
Kamera mit uns zu reden der 19-Jährige
den wir für diese Reportage Augen nennen
sollen ist Mitglied der Untergrund Zelle
und erzählt uns warum er sich dem
Widerstand angeschlossen hat
als ich bei den Protesten dabei war habe
ich oft gesehen wie das Militär Leute
geschlagen festgenommen und getötet hat
direkt vor mir
das habe ich sehr oft gesehen deshalb
habe ich mich dazu entschieden gegen
diese Schweine zu rebellieren
Augen erzählt uns dass er selbst
festgenommen und gefoltert wurde nach
seiner Freilassung haben er und ein paar
Freunde keinen anderen Weg mehr gesehen
als sich der Hund mit Gewalt zu
widersetzen auch wenn sie dafür töten
müssen
unser Team meine Anführer und Freunde
haben auf Militärposten und auf die
Verkehrspolizei geschossen
wir haben das Militär auch mit Bomben
attackiert und ihre Spitzel eliminiert
wir haben alles getan um jeden der
Verbindungen zu Militär hat zu töten
doch solche Attentate sind ihn jetzt zu
gefährlich geworden die Truppe hat sich
für eine Zeit nach Thailand
zurückgezogen und die Angriffe ruhen
gelassen
bald wollen sie wieder zurück nach
Myanmar diesmal jedoch um an der Seite
der Rebellengruppen im Dschungel zu
kämpfen
der Anführer der Zelle willigt ein und
das Equipment zu zeigen dass sie dafür
eingekauft haben und uns zu erklären
warum sie jetzt ihre Strategie ändern
müssen
wir haben untergrundmissionen in urbanen
Gebieten durchgeführt
aber jetzt sind unsere Zellen entstehten
wie Yangon oder Bago nicht mehr sicher
es gibt immer mehr Spitze
das Militär fahren wir dort jetzt
rigoros nach Gruppen wir uns
es ist ein Widerstandskampf für den vor
allem die Jugend mehren Mars viel
riskiert der 19-Jährige Augen hat einen
Anschlagsversuch auf einen Funkmast
beinahe mit dem Leben bezahlt
[Musik]
zu dem Vorfall kam es während unserer
letzten Mission als wir gerade einen
Sprengsatz zünden wollten
wir waren kurz davor den Zielort zu
erreichen aber als unsere Kameraden mit
der Bombe ankamen ist sie plötzlich
schon auf dem Motorrad hochgegangen dann
kam das Militär angefahren und ich
musste fliehen
der zu früh detonierte Sprengsatz hat
ein Großteil seines Körpers verbrannt
Augen musste schwer verletzt fliehen und
sich verstecken über Wochen konnte er
keine richtige medizinische Versorgung
bekommen seine Wunden sind deshalb nur
schlecht verheilt er hat Schmerzen kann
seine Hände kaum benutzen
ich wünsche mir dass meine Hände besser
werden ich will weiter gegen das Militär
rebellieren aber weil meine Hände so
verletzt sind kann ich nichts gegen
diese Schweine Unternehmen
seitdem der Widerstand Weg wächst werden
die Attacken und Vergeltungsschläge des
bumesischen Militärs im Land immer
brutaler
[Musik]
das geht so weit dass sich Angriffe und
Bombardements nicht nur gegen
widerstandstruppen wie die PDF richten
sondern auch wahllos gegen Zivilisten
immer wieder tauchen Beweise für
Massaker an Dorfbewohnern auf die vom
Militär begangen wurden
diese Aufnahmen aus dem Mai 2022 wurden
der Medienplattform Radio creation
zugespielt und von ihr verifiziert
sie sollen von einem offenbar verloren
gegangenen Handy eines runtersoldaten
stammen also wir haben viele getötet
indem wir ihnen die Kehlen
durchgeschnitten haben ich selbst habe
fünf umgebracht
[Musik]
mittlerweile haben sich die Kämpfe bis
an die Landesgrenzen Myanmars
ausgeweitet den Zivilisten bleibt häufig
kaum noch eine andere Wahl als in
Nachbarländer wie Thailand zu fliehen
diese Familie ist bereit mit uns vor der
Kamera zu sprechen doch weil sie Angst
vor Repression hat sollen wir keine
Namen nennen
sie erzählen uns von ähnlichen
Ereignissen wie die Vertriebenen vom
Anfang unserer Recherche wie sie einen
Angriff des rumänischen Militärs auf ihr
Heimatdorf nur knapp überlebt haben weil
sie sich gerade noch rechtzeitig
verstecken konnten
normal da waren drei Flugzeuge und auch
ein Helikopter die auf uns geschossen
haben sie sind gekommen um die Menschen
zu töten dann haben die Soldaten eine
Grube ausgehoben um die Leichen zu
vergraben da waren viele Männer und
Frauen und Kinder in der Grube sie haben
einfach alle erschossen
es ist nichts mehr da in unserem Haus
das Dach wurde von Kugeln und Raketen
zerstört und die Wände sind auch kaputt
ich weiß nicht wie die Lage dort gerade
ist wir waren schon länger nicht mehr
dort weil wir uns nicht mehr hingetraut
haben
zurück in Myanmar wie versprochen nimmt
uns der Kommandeur mit zu einem anderen
Stützpunkt der Rebellen wo wir weitere
junge pdf-kämpfer Treffen soll
bis zum Putsch ging viele von ihnen noch
in die Schule oder zur Uni jetzt
bestimmt der Umgang mit Drohnen
Mörsergranaten und das Leben im Feld
ihren Alltag
viele der kleineren pdf-gruppen
schließen sich den erfahreneren Rebellen
an um ihre Kräfte zu bündeln und sich
ausbilden zu lassen Kommandos
empfängt neue Kämpfer
komm noch mehr Leute ja
wie viele etwa 7
also
könnt ihr professionell mit den Waffen
umgehen nehmen wir an es gibt ein
Gefecht und ihr seid bewaffnet stellt
ihr euch dem Feind dann auch jawohl seid
ihr bereit dafür gut
die Kämpfe werden bald wieder losgehen
rot euch ein bisschen aus
Kämpfer wissen dass wir stärker geworden
sind seitdem sie hier im Dschungel zu
uns stoßen
wir sind stärker geworden haben wir
Truppen
mit welchen Gefahren Sie hier im Feld
leben müssen
wie groß der Widerstand wirklich ist
lässt sich nur schwer einschätzen
beobachter gehen mittlerweile von etwa
65.000 pdf-kämpfern aus die sich der
Kunter militärisch widersetzen
die exil-regierung behauptet dass etwas
mehr als die Hälfte des
gesamtteritoriums Myanmars von
antikuntergruppierung kontrolliert wird
doch es fehlen an Waffen und Munition
bei den jung pdf-mitgliedern die wir
hier treffen ist die Moral trotzdem hoch
viele sind gerade mal 18 und wirken doch
schon Kampf erprobt
so wie auch nine Mail tepcar
2004 geboren wow
hast du deinen Eltern deiner Familie
davon erzählt dass du den pdf-beitreten
wolltest und wenn ja wie haben Sie
darauf reagiert
ich habe meinen Eltern davon erzählt und
sie haben mich ermutigt sie
sympathisieren mit uns jungen Leuten und
verstehen unseren Schmerz wir alle
werden eines Tages sterben haben sie mir
gesagt um gegen die zu rebellieren die
Waffen haben müssen wir selbst zu den
Waffen greifen meine Eltern akzeptieren
das
hast du manchmal Angst denkst du darüber
nach was die und dein Kameraden zustoßen
könnte
ich wünsche mir ehrlich gesagt dass
keiner von uns verwundet wird es ist
schmerzhaft daran zu denken dass jemand
von uns sterben könnte
junge Leute wie wir haben alles geopfert
und sitzen jetzt hier im Dschungel
keiner wünscht sich das
ich will dass die Welt weiß dass wir
internationale Unterstützung brauchen
was wir hier erlebt haben macht uns klar
dass dieser Krieg bis tief in die Mitte
der Gesellschaft reicht vor allem für
die Generation Z heißt es oft Flucht
Untergrund oder Front der Hass auf das
burmesische Militär ist groß so erfahren
wir nach unserer Reise das unter source
Kommando gefangen genommen noch runter
Soldaten exekutiert worden sein
wer diesen Bürgerkrieg gewinnen wird ist
noch nicht absehbar doch fest steht je
länger er andauert desto mehr werden
Gewalt und Brutalität für eine ganze
Generation zu alltäglichen Erfahrung